Log in to your AWS account and
go to the EMR service.
This is what I see all my past clusters.
Can create a new one here.
Here you see a quick set up for
clusters.
There are two different
modes you can use.
Either you can launch a long running
cluster or do step execution.
Which runs all the jobs you add
then terminates the cluster.
Here you can see various applications
you can install in the cluster.
And this is where you select
the number of nodes and
what type of instances you'll use.
Before you get started launching
a cluster though let's consider how
we're going to get data into and
out of our cluster.
Since we won't be storing
data on this thing over time.
Typically transferring data into and
out of EC2 instances costs money.
But Amazon has a service called S3 for
storing data.
Transfers between S3 and EC2 are free.
So it makes a lot of sense
to keep your data on S3 then
transfer it to an EMR cluster for
analysis.